hi welcome to science hangout
I'm Sadashiva PI from science mission
today we have dr. Christopher Gregg a
stent professor of Neurobiology and
Anatomy from University of Utah Vedas
dr. Gregg has accomplished a lot in his
short research career until 2006 2009 he
won Alberta Heritage Foundation medical
research fellowship he won in 2006
University of Calgary Chancellor's
graduate medal 2007 to 2010 dr. Craig
received human frontiers long-term
fellowship he won in 2008 American
society for Naraku mr. Young
Investigator travel award in 2010 upend
off and science prize for neurobiology
his work was named in 2010 and IMH top
10 research advances of the year in 2011
dr. Gregg was New York stem cell
foundation Robertson neuroscience
investigator in 2012 dr. Gregg was
capstone keynote speaker 2013 to 2014 he
was associate scientific adviser Science
Translational Medicine again in 2013 he
was present Jeff thousand faculty member
genomics and genetics section welcome
dr. Gregg the science hangout thank you
so nice to have you on board
glad to be invited thank you okay can
you please talk about yourself some
background your education some research
projects etc sure I'm happy to do that
um I was a PhD student with Sam Weiss at
the University of Calgary in Canada okay
Sam is a is a pioneer in the neural stem
cell field and so
my PhD work was focused on understanding
neural stem cell biology and rolls of
endogenous neural stem cell populations
and contributing to tissue regeneration
following injury okay that was an
exciting time Sam was very animated and
highly enthusiastic mentor so those were
very infectious periods of life and we
went on to found us biotech company
called stem cell therapeutics that was
developing novel therapeutic strategies
to activate the endogenous stem cell
populations in our bodies too rigid
maybe be regenerative medicines for
stroke and multiple sclerosis and other
disorders and then I moved from there to
Catherine du Lacs lab at Harvard and
that also turned out to be a very
exciting period because this was when
next-generation sequencing technologies
were just emerging and we got to play a
role in the development of these
technologies for doing RNA seek to
resolve allele-specific expression
effects and so that was very influential
and has kind of shaped the trajectory of
my research program over the past few
years yeah
so that's where we are now now I'm an
assistant professor at the University of
Utah and we study kind of a variety of
different things including these
allele-specific expression of things
okay can you please talk about your role
models and mentors in your career sure
um I think Sam Weiss was my PhD advisor
was a very strong influence Sam sort of
preached the importance of balancing
doing exciting research with balancing a
family life and living in a really nice
place so he always did it's in a really
nice place which was which I always
found kind of funny and at the end of
the day very inspiring for my own life
and we landed here in Utah and it's just
a spectacular ly beautiful place and
part of that decision but was because of
the influence from Sam the other people
that you know we kind of looked to I
guess are people like Larry Katz Tom
Jessel Eve martyr and Richard Axel these
are labs that have been incredibly
innovative over the years but they're
also their papers are just incredibly
thorough and rigorous and so you know
we're always looking to those people to
kind of set the bar for the types of
studies that we're trying to do okay so
since you brought up families for life
Oh like I know you are busy person with
other things doing going on
so what else do you - other than
research ah well um there is a lot of
extra time outside of research and
family so those those are the two things
that occupy like 99% of my time and for
that other at 1% I like to cycle and ski
and so Utah's a great place for those
two things so those are my hobbies and
activity on the side yeah okay so can
you please talk about your lab lab
members yeah so the lab is very
interdisciplinary and that probably
likes all of the different things that I
love about science and all the different
questions one could work on 30% of the
lab works on computational problems and
bioinformatics kind of problems and
those extend from file of genomic
studies of the genomes of many different
species to studies of human genome data
we do a lot of RNA seek studies and
developing statistical methods to model
and analyze allele-specific expression
effects and RNA seek data and and then
if the other 30% of the lab is
lab-based so we have a full large wet
lab with molecular biology biochemistry
and all of those tools cell culture and
that type of stuff so people are
building tools basically the workflow is
that once you discover something using
computational and genomics based
strategies you test those hypotheses in
the wet lab and build tools and then the
other 30% is because we're an earth
science lab we want to learn how the
mechanisms that we discover actually
shape brain function and behavior and so
we've developed new ways of doing
behavioral screening in the lab that are
really efficient and really sensitive
and in brief it involves 3d printing
these arena instruct enclosures and mice
are just plugged into these arenas and
they can behave in those arenas and
forage and do all kinds of instinctive
and natural behaviors and then we
analyze and capture all that data from
video and use learning based strategies
to to extract their patterns of behavior
or detect phenotypes and so so we have
this kind of high-throughput way of
screening for behavioral phenotypes
following a bunch of different
manipulations and that's really useful
for us so that's the pipeline and that's
and then the lab is populated by people
that are interested in all of those
different areas and they come from all
around the world
Switzerland China Canada we've had all
kinds of people from around the u.s.
coming in the lab and so it's really
diverse and fun group of people yeah so
how do you how do you how do you mentor
them how do you like what is your how do
you interact like what kind of do you
have any open-door policy or something
like that um so yeah I'm I'm very at my
stage of career I'm very engaged in the
research program and the mentorship of
the people so I meet once a week with
every person individually we have a lab
meeting every week and um I'm a
pretty active team member on all of the
projects so nobody is left to struggle
on their own and people tend to gather
in groups and in teams and and I think
that that works out really well the you
know how I kind of approach approach the
mentorship problem really depends on the
person some people like to be left alone
and can work away on their problems and
seek out feedback when they're ready for
that and I I think that's great and
people that kind of want to work in
secret on top secret ideas and then tell
me when they feel oh that's fine and
other people really want more guidance
especially at the beginning of their PhD
work or postdocs that works just fine -
yeah everybody okay nobody has a
different style you know that's good
yeah let's let's talk about more science
like you have been doing the stem cells
and gene expressions and all those
things and I saw your recent work pretty
interesting so can you please go ahead
and present your work if you don't mind
yeah sure so I'll present an overview of
this new paper we just had come out in
neuron which um which is about a little
specific epigenetic thing so I'll just
share the screen here okay so this story
was the work of a graduate student in a
way chopped Wang and a bio informatician
in the lab named Elliot Farris and the
the background to the project is simply
that we wanted to understand what is the
landscape of epigenetic allelic effects
in the mammalian brain and in most cases
the way people think about
allele-specific expression we all know
that you get one copy from your mom and
one copy from your dad for most genes in
the genome autosomal genes
and at the cellular level we think in
most cases that both alleles are
expressed relatively equally and and so
one example of kind of illustration of
how that works but if you get an
epigenetic mark that impacts one allele
and not the other then you can get an
asymmetry and some cells may may have
these colors of epigenetic allele
specific effects and we're interested in
learning more about those and we think
that there's a strong rationale for
doing that because as we understand more
and more about the genetics of mental
illness was becoming clear is that most
of the genetic risk factors are
heterozygous which means that just one
allele is impacted it's estimated that
80 percent of de novo coding sequence
variants for example in autism are
paternally derived so the maternal
allele is not impacted in those cases in
the same way 20% are maternally derived
55% of de novo copy number variants only
come from the mother and and from what
we can tell recessive mutations do not
contribute appreciably to schizophrenia
or autism risk and we're learning more
and more about the fact that paternal
age is a risk factor for mental illness
and other disorders because of an
increase in germ cell mutations over age
and so over time we get on average about
two new mutations per year in the male
germline and so these accumulate over
time um and epigenetic allelic effects
can interact with heterozygous mutations
in potentially interesting ways at the
cellular level
our current picture is of this kind of
by allelic case where one allele is
mutated and the other alleles wild-type
and if you look inside of a cell we
would expect that both the mutated and
the wild-type allele would be expressed
if we have a heterozygous mutation but
in the case of an epigenetic allelic
effect
you might have some cells where the
epigenetic mark arose on the mutated
allele and so as a consequence only the
wild type copy is expressed and maybe
that cell doesn't experience the impact
of the mutation as strongly or on the
other hand you could have a
subpopulation of cells where the
epigenetic mark silenced the wild-type
allele and those cells only express the
mutated allele and that might be bad and
so one can envision a scenario where
these sorts of mono allelic mutant
allele expressing cells are contributing
to dysfunction we know a little bit
about or quite a lot expose about
epigenetic allelic effects from a
phenomenon called genomic imprinting and
this is a scenario where epigenetic
marks are inherited on chromosomes you
get from your father that are different
from the marks that are inherited from
the chromosomes you get from your mother
and as a consequence in offspring those
marks are maintained in most cases and
result in a symmetries in gene
expression coming from maternal versus
paternal alleles for a handful of genes
in the genome and that can have really
interesting consequences for our
understanding of genetic risk so for
example Angelman syndrome is caused by a
deletion of a cluster of imprinted genes
on chromosome 15 and if you get that
deletion from your mother then you will
get this angel in syndrome as a
consequence of losing maternal expressed
imprinted gene called ub 3 a and so this
syndrome is characterized by a number of
cognitive features one of them is
intellectual disability this is an
autism spectrum disorder and these
individuals are characteristically very
happy and affable in contrast if you get
the same mutation from your father so
the turtle alleles impacted but the
maternal is not we get a totally
different disorder called prader-willi
syndrome and that happens because of the
deletion of a bunch of paternally
expressed imprinted genes in the same
cluster and and so because these
individuals have an insatiable appetite
that it develops later in childhood
schizophrenia and autism they go through
puberty early and they develop morbid
obesity and so the take-home message
here is these epigenetic allelic effects
can interact with heterozygous mutations
in interesting ways that shape disease
risk in this case if you get the same
mutation from your mom versus your dad
you get two different disorders and we
want to know more about this phenomenon
and about the landscape of epigenetic
allelic effects that exist in vivo we
know about canonical imprinting like I
just talked about and in females we also
know about the phenomenon of random X
inactivation and this is the scenario in
which some cells randomly choose to
express the paternally inherited x
chromosome and silenced the maternal and
vice-versa
in other cells and so you get this
random mono allelic expression for
x-linked genes and we want to know is
that all we need to worry about or are
there other forms of epigenetic allelic
effects that could be discovered in vivo
and are existing that we don't know
about our idea to start is basically to
tell test the null hypothesis that
maternal and paternal alleles are
co-expressed
and so you imagine a whole bunch of
genetically identical mice and you
measure gene expression in a particular
tissue in each individual animal your
dissection or the physiological state of
the animals will vary a little bit
between and well the animal even though
they're genetically the same and so
there will be variance in the expression
level for a given gene and we expect
that for most autism
well genes the maternal and paternal
alleles will vary in expression level
together they'll go up and down together
because they're coagulated and what we
want to discover are genes where that is
not the case so if the maternal nil goes
up maybe the paternal allele is doing
something else essentially the
regulation of the two alleles is
decoupled from each other due to non
genetic effects and we call these
differential allele expression effects
so our strategy to find these involves
the use of two inbred lines of mice and
we one of them is called caste æneas and
the other is called black six and we
cross those two inbred lines to generate
an f1 hybrid Mouse that's half caste
half black six and then you can perform
RNA seek on any tissue that you're
interested in at any particular
developmental stage that you're
interested in and do what's called
phasing the RNA seek reads according to
the allele of origin so for example in
the illustration here all of the reads
are phased and there seem to be more
read so there are more reads coming from
the maternal allele compared to the
paternal allele and I know who's the mom
in this cross it's the caste aeneas
strain so there's more rates coming from
the caste Aeneas allele in the black six
who's the father we can investigate
parental affects potentially with this
strategy like imprinting effects by
flipping this the cross so that black
six is the mother and caste Aeneas is
now the father you look in the
reciprocal hybrid phase the reads and in
this example the bias in the expression
is always following the parental origin
of the allele and in this case showing a
maternal allele expression effect so
we've used that approach in the past to
study imprinting but in the new study
what we wanted to do was find these
allele Co expression effects and so we
developed an approach to isolate the the
expression variants between
and individuals using the same data for
this gene Foucault to which is an
example we've done RNA seek on 18
different individuals and there is this
jitter in the data that you can see and
so the data the expression level of the
maternal allele is in red and the
paternal allele in the blue circles and
you can see that they go up and down
together and this is what we would
expect for most autosomal genes that the
maternal and paternal alleles are
tightly co-regulated and highly
correlated across this type of
experimental design so we apply that
strategy in a genome-wide manner and
here's the data for a Foucault - again
plotted in a different way the maternal
allele expression is plotted against the
paternal expression level and it's
highly correlated to plus 0.9 and we're
interested in discovering genes like the
mp7 and adore to be that have these
differential allele expression effects
the expression of maternal and paternal
alleles for BMP seven are largely
uncorrelated so if the maternal allele
goes up the paternal allele does
something else is it's largely decoupled
add or to be as a negative allele
correlation effect so if the maternal
allele goes up the paternal allele
expression goes down and and that is a
very interesting phenomenon to have
uncovered but we have an intellectual
kind of framework to be thinking about
those types of effects and it in endless
Allah and it comes from random mono
allelic x-inactivation and female so so
let me explain here with this slide this
is a terrific study from Jeremy Nathan's
group and the Nathans lab generated
reporter lines where the X chromosome
from the father is labeled in red with
dimer tomato and the maternal X from the
mother is labeled in these offspring we
GFP and they look across different
individuals and show these incredible
mosaic patterns so for example in this
big picture of the brain half of the
brain largely chose the maternal x
chromosome and the other half largely
chose the paternal X chromosome and we
look between different individuals
within a litter there'll be some that
are largely largely choosing the
paternal x and some that largely choose
the maternal x and everything in between
and even even direct siblings can vary
dramatically so what's important here is
if you're looking across different
individuals at random x and activation
more maternal x expressing cells always
come at the expense of paternal x
expressing cells so those two are
negatively correlated and so what that
means in our data is that if we are
seeking to discover random mono allelic
effects like x-linked genes then more
maternal allele expression will come at
the expense of paternal allele
expression at the cellular level and
vice versa and so they will be
negatively correlated just like a door
to be is negatively correlated ok so
that's a putative random mono allelic
effect finally look expression at the
cellular level in the case that the
maternal paternal Leal's are equally
core equally co-expressed
should manifest as highly correlated
expression in our data or RNA seek data
and then there can be other more complex
scenarios so imprinting for example
where one allele is completely off will
manifest as no correlation between the
two alleles because there is no
expression from one parent and cell
type-specific random on of allelic
effects where you've got random anoleis
ism in some cells but not others that
will drive this correlation down and so
as a consequence you get low correlation
and there might be something like the
BMP 7 case another way to get that type
of effect
be to have cell type-specific imprinting
where some cells are by allelic and
other cells are imprinted and so that
again drives this correlation down and
as a consequence you get this kind of
low effect so this strategy using our
RNA seek based approach to look at
allelic expression effects in any tissue
brain region or developmental aids that
you're interested in gives us a way to
screen across the landscape of potential
epigenetic allelic effects and and
discover what's present but one of the
big problems that we had to overcome was
that you could get a low correlation
between two alleles just due to
technical noise in the data and and so
we had to innovate in that space to come
up with a statistical framework that
allows us to estimate the 95% confidence
interval for the true underlying
biological correlation between the two
alleles and so a lot of that work is in
the supplement but in brief it works
really well and x-linked genes for
example are plotted here and they trend
towards negative allele correlation and
the confidence intervals are shown there
for the for the true by underlying
biological effect imprinted genes have
no correlation between their alleles and
then here's an example of autosomal
genes that have highly correlated
alleles right so now we have this
framework to do the screen and we're
going to do an in vivo screen to look at
the landscape of allelic effects first
of all in the adult female dorsal raphe
nucleus and that's an interesting area
of the brain because it is the largest
search energy nucleus of brain and it's
linked to a lot of different forms of
mental illness and it modulates
everything from pain feeding behavior
and anxiety
behaviors to social behaviors and other
aspects of the internet function so
that's in part why we focused on it and
we profiled these allele co-expression
effects in that region of the brain and
we first looked at x-linked genes in
these females because they are controls
for us internal controls and and we're
plotting in this plot the 95 percent
confidence intervals for each of the
over 500 x-linked genes expressed in the
dorsal raphe nucleus in these female
brains and what this shows in blue and
green and orange is that the 95%
confidence intervals for these x-linked
genes are shifted towards way from plus
1 and down towards zero
or to the negative to a negative
correlation and so that's what we want
to see and that means there our approach
across genes with different expression
levels and variance characteristics our
approach can detect the differential
expression of x-linked genes in vivo so
now we apply the same screen to
autosomal genes and this is showing all
the genes on chromosome 12 and what you
can see immediately is that the whole
distribution for the confidence
intervals is shifted towards +1 and
that's consistent with our expectation
that most autosomal genes Co Express
their alleles but the ones that are
highlighted in orange dark blue light
blue and green are genes that have
allele co-expression effects or
differential expression effects that are
similar to x-linked genes so we have
discovered with our screen genes on the
autosomes that show putative random mono
allelic effects like x-linked genes in
this part of the brain um so the we then
use the screen to study these
differential allele express effects at
different stages and
tissues and different brain regions so
we profiled allelic effects in the
neonatal brain at postnatal day five in
the dorsal raphe nucleus at P 15 in
juveniles and in adults and the
surprising discovery was that there was
a large fraction of genes over 85% of
genes that exhibit high confidence
differential allele expression effects
in the neonatal brain so in that
developing brain this decoupling of the
two alleles was very frequent but the
effects go away in juveniles by and
large and only 10% of genes in the P 15
raphe nucleus have these differential
allelic effects and similarly in the
adult brain only 10% so that's the
orange the green and the blue there is a
subgroup of genes that have tightly
co-expressed alleles very very highly
correlated and we indicate those with
these red bars they're relatively rare
in the neonatal brain but increase in
frequency as brain development kind of
matures and and completes the
differential allelic effects are present
in both the raphe nucleus and in the
arcuate nucleus the a RN of the
hypothalamus these effects are not
unique to the brain they're also present
in the liver and in the muscle and so
we've uncovered these effects across
different tissue types the liver is
endoderm derived in the skeletal muscle
we looked at is visa term derived so our
screen has uncovered these putative
random mono allelic effects or
differential allelic expression effects
in different tissue types and we want to
really know what these effects are at
the cellular level in a previous study
we developed a way of using RNA scope
probes to detect allele-specific
expression at the cellular level in
brain tissue sections and so the way
this works is we design
in these aren't escaped RNA scope probes
to rapidly processed introns in the
nascent RNA and that allows us to
resolve transcription on the DNA allele
and so we can see transcriptionally
active alleles in these cells and here's
an example of here are neurons in the
adult mouse brain and we're staining
using this approach for synapse in - and
you can see two dots in the nucleus of
each of these neurons four synapse and
two and that's because this gene is by
allelic both alleles are active but this
is a female brain and we're looking also
at a gene called monoamine oxidase a
which is excellent and so in the female
brain there should only be one
transcriptionally active copy because of
random X inactivation and that's why you
see only one blue dot in these positive
cells and so we think our approach can
detect random on of allelic versus by
allelic expression effects in vivo and
it allows us then to go on and test what
these effects that we uncovered with the
RNA seek screen what are they at the
cellular level so we design probes to
detect nascent RNA for genes that show a
little Co expression like M tap on B and
genes that show differential allele
expression effects like beauty for and
what we find is that genes with Coach
press Delisle are largely by allelic at
the cellular level that's why you see
two dots in each of these nuclei in the
in these brain tissue sections for this
gene M tap one B and just one dot in the
cells for BMP for when we do this for
many genes and look at the linear
relationship between the percentage of
mono allelic cells in the brain and the
allele of the RNA seek allele
correlation score there is a negative
linear relationship which is what we
expect and it indicates that genes with
low allele correlation
have a high number of mono allelic cells
in the brain and genes with highly
co-expressed tightly correlated alleles
are associated with a higher number of
by allelic cells in the brain I'll just
point out that this scale starts at 30%
because 30% of cells are mono allelic
because of sectioning artifacts where we
cut the nucleus in half okay so we have
this picture emerging that there are
these random on of allelic effects that
we've discovered in in vivo and that are
kind of like X inactivation in in some
ways and we want to know whether they
can interact with heterozygous mutations
to actually shape genetic architecture
at the cellular level so so like I was
saying before our current vision of most
autosomal genes is that they will
express the wild type in the mutant
alleles in a by allelic manner at the
cellular level
but with these allele specific
epigenetic effects we expect to get some
cells that are mono allelic for the
wild-type monolithic mutant only
expressed in the mutant allele or mono
allelic wild-type only expressing the
wild-type allele if you have had arose
expectation and this is an experiment
that we can do in mice we take advantage
of available knockout reporter lines
where lag Z has been knocked in for
example into the into one allele for
bmp4 and so that alleles labeled with
the lac c trans gene and the other
alleles wild-type and now we design RNA
scope probes to the mRNA instead of the
nascent RNA we're detecting the mRNA
here for lac Z and for being the mutated
allele and for BMP for the wild-type
allele and what was exciting to us is
that when we looked in the brains of
these animals and other p5 or in adults
there were mosaics of cells that were
apparent some cells like C here or C
prime is mostly red and so these are all
these all these red dots are individual
acts
transcripts and so this cell is
expressing the mutated like Z allele but
not the wild-type allele which is in
blue here's an example of a cell that's
expressing the wild-type allele but not
the like Z allele and here is an example
of a by allelic cell that expresses both
alleles all of these in the same field
of view in the adult we can see the same
thing mono allelic mutant cells mono
allelic wild-type cells and by allelic
cells we looked at three different
transgenic reporter knockin reporter
lines for different genes BMP seven BMP
for like I just showed an ad or to be
and in all cases we were able to see
wild-type allele mono allelic cells
mutant mono allelic cells for the
liangzi allele and by allelic cells and
we also scored cells that are
predominantly expressing the mutant
allele but have maybe one transcript
apparent or the wild-type allele or on
the other hand cells that predominantly
express the wild-type believe what we
found evidence for one or two
transcripts of the mutant allele so
these are like biased we counted the
number of those five different
categories of cells in different regions
of the brain for example in the dorsal
raphe and periaqueductal gray regions
and in in in meningeal cells and what we
found is that these mono allelic
wild-type and mutant cells are the
predominant population of BMP seven and
bmp4 positive cells in the
periaqueductal gray region but they're
very rare amongst meningeal cells and
the vast majority of meningeal cells are
by allele and that's interesting because
it means that the genetic architecture
of the cells in these different regions
of the brain differ in terms of these
epigenetic genetic effects shape the
expression of the heterozygous mutation
so our finding so far suggested that we
are screen had uncovered successfully
genes that exhibit the differential
allele expression effects and that those
effects can interact with heterozygous
variants to into shape genetic
architecture at the cellular level in
vivo and the implications for
understanding mental illness are
potentially interesting because it means
that one hypothesis is that some cells
exist that are expressing a mutated the
preferentially expressing the mutated
allele when you get a heterozygous
mutation in a risk gene for autism for
example or schizophrenia and so we will
and so we wanted to know whether these
effects actually even exists in the
primate brain and if they do exist do
they impact genes linked to mental
illness and this turns out to be very
challenging to do in humans but we were
able to do it in macaques cinema cinema
Liga's macaques turned out to be very
polymorphic and so we were able to do
matings between males and females
generate daughters and we do DNA whole
genome sequencing on the parents to
identify polymorphic sites that
distinguish the maternal paternal
alleles in the daughters and we do RNA
seek on the daughter so that we can
phase maternal reads according to the
maternal and paternal allelic origin so
to make a long story short this approach
works and we're able to plot the
expression of paternal allele versus
maternal allele for these genes and we
discover genes that tightly come express
their alleles in the primate brain but
also very excitingly fine genes that
show these differential allele
expression effects as well like CN TN
one here when we look across all the
genes that we were able to profile we
are able to see in that mix that several
have been implicated in different forms
of mental illness so for example by
disorder BP in this graph autism
spectrum disorder and schizophrenia we
were able to find genes that are risk
genes for those different disorders and
ascertain their allelic co-expression
patterns in the primate brain in the
dorsal raphe nucleus and we found that
there are genes with tightly
co-expressed alleles that are risk
factors but we also found genes that
show evidence for the decoupling of the
two alleles showing differential allele
expression effects and we're going to
focus on two of those in particular deaf
one and CNT and ap two which are risk
factors for autism spectrum disorder and
influence language development so we
want to learn we predict for CNT and ap2
that it's going to be largely by allelic
in the primate brain because the alleles
are tightly co-expressed and for deaf
one that will be largely mono allelic
because we see differential of the
expression effects and and so we design
our nascent RNA and c2 probes for those
two genes and obtain post-mortem brain
tissue from the orbital frontal cortex
Broca's area the anterior cingulate and
the raf a for females humans from the
human brain and we get that tissue from
third to er from 12 unrelated females
and what we're interested to see is that
CNT and AP to predominantly shall by
allelic expression in the anterior
cingulate cortex and in the orbital
frontal cortex so you see the two dots
there but deaf one predominately showed
mono allelic expression in the human
brain and these effects were not just
sporadic cases in one example if you
look across many unrelated individuals
here the orange bar shows the proportion
of positive cells for deaf one that are
mono Lila and the blue bar shows the by
allelic cells and you can see over 80
the cells are mono allelic and that's
reproducible across different unrelated
individuals on the other hand CMT and
ap2 is predominantly by allelic and that
is reproducible across those different
individuals and so we think that these
are effects that are non genetic in
origin because of their reproducibility
across these people and in between
macaque and human so we've learned that
there appear to be diverse epigenetic
allelic effects in vivo and that impact
all the major tissue types we've looked
at so far and occur in both mice and
primates these effects shape genetic
architecture at the cellular level and
interact these heterozygous mutations
and they appear to be very prevalent in
the developing brain but are reduced in
the adult brain nonetheless still
impacting around ten percent of genes so
all things being equal your the twins
mark and Scott Kelly at NASA all things
being equal these guys been genetically
the same but we predict that there will
be these epigenetic allelic effects that
introduce variation into the system for
heterozygous variants and so the lab
carries on trying to think about and
understand what these effects are in
particular we want to know how stable
these effects are they could be
temporarily very transient certainly
some of them are confined to development
and we want to know some of them are
more stable and some are very unstable
and so we're trying to develop
approaches to to look at that and think
about why they exist and what function
they may serve one model is that
differential allele expression effects
may function to help resolve chromatin
conformation incompatibilities in the
genome it's frequently the case that
regulatory elements for one gene sit
inside of introns for another gene for
example
so imagine gene one and gene two here
and a regulatory element maybe sits in
the intron of gene one and as a
consequence for gene to be expressed
gene one needs to kind of fold and bring
that enhancer element in contract with
the promoter for g2 and this may be a
kind of confirmation in compatibility
that that does not allow gene 1 to be
expressed and and so when gene 2 is on
so you can have both at the same time
and if you have that confirmation on
both alleles gene 1 doesn't get to be on
but gene 2 does and if a cell wants to
have gene 1 and gene - on at the same
time one way to resolve that might be to
have different sort of chromatin
confirmations and gene expression
programs coming stochastically from the
two alleles and that would allow gene 1
to be on and gene 2 to be on and in that
scenario and indeed in the imprinting
field there are examples of genes
competing with each other for access to
enhancers and these types of things and
having flexibility and how your two
alleles are used may help to allow for
diversity of different gene expression
programs in a Cell we have learned that
the differential allele expression
effects are particularly enriched in the
brain and cells at this early stage of
development are highly plastic
responding to environmental information
and developmental signals in a new study
that is on its way we've learned that
human differential allele expression
effects appear to be highly enriched in
the adult in some cells like leukocytes
and these cells tend to be highly
plastic and need to be able to respond
to signals in the environment in order
to respond to infection and these types
of things and so one idea is that
differential allele expression effects
might be important because they allow
cells to be in this kind of poised
plastic state and that may be important
in shaping cell fate during development
it may how cells respond to
environmental signals like critical
periods of development where you're
getting you know you have to do
the brain for example needs to respond
to sensory input in a particular way and
stabilize that stress diet disease and
infection these types of things we
learned that we think these effects are
likely important for shaping how
heterozygous mutations are expressed and
we're going to learn in the future I
hope whether they interact with
heterozygous mutations from see the
variation and disease risk so I'll just
stop
I get the picture out of the card lab
but the beautiful mom and the Institute
here um they're certainly interested in
looking challenge students and postdocs
who come and want to come and work on
many different projects that are going
on in the lab you're the funding
agencies that support work and the
people that led the party backed up
today uh Rach I long a graduate student
and Elliott diversify or petition in lab
and with that I will stop can you place
a unsheathe thank you yeah the thanks
Chris it is very nice presentation very
interesting great or something's not so
something something new to think about
something new to I mean like really
there is a lot of scope in the thank you
uh and one of the things like in one of
the initial slides you had mentioned
about Patterson early you have more
mutations transfer as the good men get
older like haha do you have any idea or
like any research has been done why it
is so why not maternal why only fatter
now so the the reason is then the
paternal German is constantly paternal
germline cells are constantly dividing
to generate new sperm and so as a
consequence of constantly replicating
your genome you just accumulate errors
over time but eggs who cites females are
born with a certain number of ooh
and that they are not continually
produced throughout life really okay
okay and does it have like I mean like
these mutations like I've seen like with
the mutations like when you get older
you'll have more of these genetic
disorders and all those things in your
offspring so yeah so how does it like
like in some you see some you don't like
does your allelic like certain type of
these orders have something to do with
that um well we think that for those
mutations are coming through the
germline these effects may shape how
what type of disorder an individual
might get what might be the sort of
phenotypes that characterize that
disorder and whether they don't get a
disorder so you know we know for example
that all of us actually in our genome
sequence have bonafide disease-causing
mutations something like about a hundred
on average but we're all kind of walking
around healthy and fine right and so
there are a variety of different
explanation for whether it is the case
but we're interested in whether these
allelic effects play a role know
so is that any like I mean like I'm
asking the future question here
yeah like is that is that anything like
has anybody done anything related to
these are awesome us or anything because
why do some get why do some don't
as this allelic differential expression
does it matter yeah yeah so we are
interested in those questions and we are
pursuing all of those questions right
now in part the major goal is to develop
understanding of the landscape of these
effects in the human uh-huh in regions
and healthy individual and and then
we're collecting resources to map these
effects and people that get disease and
learn how these effects change in
disease Fisher so you know your question
is right on target that's
that's where it's going yeah and is
there any specific issue you could use
or like of course the blood is may not
be the right thing to do it says really
like this short off life be there so is
there any muscle or like is it something
this is specific okay some muscle
disorders you may be able to I mean like
in the humans you can get samples of
disease and then people who don't have
disease and is it possible to have a
kind of expository a allelic gene
expression differential in your case
maybe you are prone to some muscle
disorders down the road yeah that's um
definitely of interest to us we're
finding so far that there's a lot of
information we can get from human blood
but we think that and we're doing
studies of human brain we haven't yet
started to look at diseased human brain
but that's certainly in the queue and
those are absolutely available we will
be able to do that it's just a matter of
time and funding in Minooka IIIi think
we are almost out of time
race so it's very nice talking to you
really I appreciate you taking time and
joining us thank you so much thank you
see you later
you bye